Justin do you ever see yourself getting
married
no not on paper no absolutely not I
believe in love and marriage and in
regards to taking care of a woman fully
and your responsibilities of the father
and a provider and protector 100 in fact
I think that's probably what's broken
about the world but in regards to
letting the state get into all my
businesses that took me over a decade to
build absolutely not know how do you
think you're gonna get to the place of
that marriage you want with that family
and
that Lifelong Love they just I didn't
say I didn't have family or children in
your business oh I see okay
so you want to keep it private is what
you're saying that's what I said
Justin has I might have multiple family
you never know I might like family more
than you so much I have five
do you have multiple family I think it's
good if there's one dad and there's not
a bunch of step parents involved and the
dad can be the hero and those five
families live a 10x better life than
they would have otherwise yes ma'am I do
but you don't think that it will be
ultimately a an opportunity for jealousy
or disharmony amongst women are always
going to be jealous what's changed about
that women been jealous all the way
through time so I'm not jealous in my
marriage I don't care about your
marriage I'm talking about mine I don't
think having multiple families is a
problem if there's one dad and he's the
hero on all those families what do you
think about that
I haven't really thought about that like
to be honest with you I'm not so close
to thinking that that wouldn't
necessarily work or not I don't have
enough information to have an opinion on
that I I don't okay I'll say this go
ahead it's hard enough to be an
efficient dead in a family of seven sure
I know plenty of dads who are families
of seven eight kids let me tell you some
of those kids get neglected sure it's
hard enough being an efficient Dad when
you're divorced or an efficient parent
period when you're splitting custody all
the time why because you're not there
for the kid now imagine having to split
your energy and your time between being
successful and multiple families I'm not
even talking about the morality I don't
really care I'm just talking about do
you even have the time and the energy to
be [__] present um
when I hear a lot of these guys talk
about starting families all they ever
seem to really talk about is the money I
could provide them with a better life
well what does that really look like we
ask most kids would you rather have a
dad who brought home a million dollars
but was never around or a father who was
present all the time but brought a
middle class income and mostly I'm going
to choose the second option why well
provided you have a good father parent
why because at the end of the day
they're actually in your life
money can't replace everything for
parenting especially the the best
outcomes for children are where both
parents are present and involved in
their children's lives you can't just
fix that with finances and I think it's
a bit of a delusion I hear when people
speak about these things where they're
just like oh you know I'll have seven or
eight families and then afterwards I'll
take care of everybody and pay for every
bill it's like you can pay for stuff but
not everything can be bought with money
now I've seen some I've seen some like
it's cool some rich kids
they got fresh and fit and stuff like
that
choose
clothes latest disc man yeah that's how
old I am
a mess
a mess I'm feeling pretty and I'm not
saying every rich kids and stuff like
that but the ones the ones that when it
was a party being thrown that's where
the party was at because the parents
were often not there that's my answer
I'm gonna run my situation exactly how I
want to and generally when I do that
that's when I have the most happiness
let's say in my life so so
and you would want that for your
daughters
yeah yeah I I live my life
unapologetically on my terms so if my
daughter is that are overly spoiled and
and educated in every way and have
friends all over the world and World
traveled in the best schools in the
world if they have a problem with me at
the end of the day then they can kick
rocks too I I'm not going to send for my
daughters I love them fully but if they
grow up and turn into a person that
doesn't want to get in line with me or
at least look here's my goal as a parent
teach my children how the world Works
give them the skills so they can live on
their own terms and give them choice if
they choose not to make me part of their
life after I've given them those things
I've still succeeded as a father
that's a funny sentence I'm not gonna
simp for my daughters
I feel like when I see online culture
bleed into real life I just cringe a
little bit
I don't really think
I don't care nobody says I don't really
I don't think I've ever heard a girl
missing I never simply for my daughters
get in line [__]
I'm just like if there's one person or
two people you should be simping for is
probably your wife and your daughters
maybe I'm I'm a [__] in this area I
just out of every dad I've ever seen
always suits for their daughters and I I
and they love it they enjoy it if it's
rewarding it's probably one of the best
things in their lives okay that's why
they have that guy I don't like that
word used with daughter all right I
agree I don't like those stop saying
it's weird right
don't say that [__] spend your daughter
and your wife that's some weird [__] I
mean in fact so you should don't don't
say that you should that's the people
you've chosen it's not simping that's
your daughter hold up hold up you're
literally gonna die for her if she's
like a risk you're gonna die for her
you're gonna give up all your valuable
possessions that's your daughter okay
let's that's that simple hold up
according to these right people that's
something bro that is not I agree but
we're okay let's not let's not use that
okay if we agree the thing is I've
unplugged from The Matrix you haven't
that's why I'm using the right words I
just realized today they should be you I
am 33 years old and I just realized
today that I simp for my mom like I just
realized that I fetishized my no why did
you make it sexual no it's not sexual
fetishizing is
don't be weird don't be weird no
Symphony um as a soldier of Allah I do
not approve I've really unplugged from
The Matrix
no simple it's hella weird you can't sin
for your daughter
oh look at him sipping for his daughter
yo bros before hoes what you gonna it's
gonna be your best win and you know what
the way that these guys talk you know
they don't have any daughters I I would
bet my life savings on the fact that
they don't I would not not ones that
they're actually in their lives I don't
believe it I just don't believe I
wouldn't know I wouldn't know I don't
believe I think there's weirdos like
that out there I don't I don't believe
that you're involved heavily in the
child's life you take care of them on a
regular basis and you're saying yeah I
would want my daughter to be part of
some guy's Harem or yeah uh I I I I I I
don't I don't sit for my I just don't
but I don't believe it yeah I live my
life unapologetically on my terms so if
my daughter is that are overly spoiled
and and educated in every way and have
friends all over the world and World
traveled in the best schools in the
world if they have a problem with me at
the end of the day then they can kick
rocks too you guys notice and the things
that he says that he's given to his
daughters overly spoiled cool well
educated cool well traveled
cool there's no mentions of love and
awareness there's no mentions of
investing my time and energy into
everything there's just mentions of
material Goods they don't talk about
that bonding time they don't talk about
the experience of seeing the first words
or watching them develop or grow it's
never that stuff it's always money
that's the same thing it's money money
that's a simple stuff
okay just to be fair I think what he's
trying to say by the simping stuff which
we can find better words right
I think it's really just like abide by
what the daughter or being there's a lot
of parents out there that are being led
by their kids
that it's everything that their kids
want and they're like what we call in
French
like the kid is the king and you will
buy by all the Tantrums of the kid I
think to be fair that's what he would
mean look here's my goal as a parent
teach my children how the world Works
give them the skills so they can live on
their own terms and give them choice if
they choose not to make me part of their
life after I've given them those things
I've still succeeded as a father but I
guess I'm asking if you're comfortable
answering obviously but are you wanting
to be a role model for your kids is that
part a thousand percent a father should
show up in every way for his children I
think I'll be better than most fathers
regardless of how many children I have I
might have a hundred okay preach do you
think you could have multiple wives and
invest in each one of them equally in
terms of time and dedication no why I'm
curious from your Olympics because as
you know
go ahead
the way you looked at me you look tired
you gave me a lie
cause as you know all right go for it
I'm not really good with keeping an
agenda that's why I have someone that
does that for me gotcha that's for my
business [__]
imagine multiple I can't do it what you
say multiple what wives whatever like
love them equally and stuff like that
you can't get an agenda for your wives
oh no no imagine you got a personal
assistant for all my wives yeah what if
your personal assistant became one of
your wives too she started [__] up
the dates like this [__] didn't bring
me no cookies
birthday Monday me hey Tuesday me again
Wednesday Thursday Friday Saturday me
Sunday then [__]
I just want to see I want to see this
red pill Guru guy who's got multiple
wives who are all happy with the
situation multiple kids who are all
happy with the situation and they've
maintained over 15 years because I'm
going to be honest with you most of
these guys it sounds like they live a
pipe trick but I could be underwear
but you have other relationships with
other women too what does that have to
do with anything wait I'm just wondering
if you think I haven't even said that
I'm just saying like if I want to I will
but you don't think that's a problem for
your daughter to know that about their
dad that he has multiple Mysteries
except to my daughter man
you know but do you want your daughter
to have a guy like that long term if he
takes care of her in every way and she
has a much better life because of it
yeah I'm cool with that wait do you want
to have 100 kids I'm gonna have a bunch
of kids yeah I believe in having kids
man so there's there's too many dumbass
people having kids might as well have a
smart person have some dude it's Justin
Loki about to repopulate the world kids
are awesome
single-handedly reverse the declining
they got all these single women out here
talking [__] about [__] man well cool
I'll have babies with you what's up now
part of it is being a smart ass right
now right to be honest but look if if a
guy decides to have a bunch of children
I mean you see it happen all the time
God gets married he's a shitty father
shitty husband ends up getting a divorce
and then goes have and has babies with
the next chick doing the same thing I'm
doing this up I'm not a lying coward
about it I hear you I I see that I see
what it is but I think the big questions
I mean it seems like you're really
focused on self-improvement which is
awesome and so I guess my question would
be is it ID like what are we striving
towards individually right and what do
we think is best for society and I think
kids want to know their parents love
each other and are committed till death
do they part to each other yep didn't
say any of that wasn't true but
everyone's saying that's not true okay
but do you think it would be a little
bit
um confusing for one of your kids if
they found out let's say theoretically
because if they trust me enough to come
to me I'll just tell them the truth what
are we talking about I'm not hiding from
anything I just told you I understand it
seems like you're challenging because
you have a problem with it I simply
don't care
so your your kids are saying you don't
care if they find out you have multiple
Mistresses if I had multiple women and
then my kids came to me then I would
just talk to them like like an adult if
they're adult enough to ask I'm adult
enough to tell them well whatever they
ask I'm there for
you that's it
find somebody else I don't feel bad I'm
gonna live in truth here's the
difference between me and most men most
men are doing this [__] behind people's
back right like a [__] coward and
they're not even giving the family the
life that they deserve so if I choose to
do that in the future which I have not
said I'm gonna do
then so be it that point are you saying
yes true what one well that he's trying
to say truth if you say that he's trying
to be true truthful if if he lives by
that then good if he's able to achieve
that great I mean the question isn't
whether or not what he's saying is
truthful that's irrelevance whether or
not it's good for society or the
families involved some men cheat and
have second families I'm going to be
upfront about it it doesn't change the
fact that it's still bad for the kids
the point is that whether or not he's
true that's like saying listen uh you
know me personally I'm up front about
every wrong thing I do just because
you're upfront about it doesn't make it
any less better no it is it is it is I
killed 50 people you know what I mean I
see yeah that's gonna ask you one more
question far away okay
um if you haven't placed in only one
place in your heart for one woman or you
want to have one woman in your heart I
think you said why don't you just commit
to one and choose to be faithful to her
I'm just not wired that way I spent my
whole 20s trying to fix myself control
you you work out you do business you can
possess your own your own power
I am that's not how I am you think I
might be a limited mindset I think it's
none of your business but I don't want
you to think I'm triggered by you I'm
not I saw somebody say that I think
that's interesting I think you're
annoying but I'm not sure you know what
I'm saying no you are you're annoying in
like this goody two shoes type way and
that's fine uh I'm gonna live my life on
my terms on apologize unapologetically
like truly so uh you can ask me this 85
different ways at the end of the day I'm
gonna walk out of here the same man yeah
I think that if you're if your kids ask
you she's telling the truth 100 there's
no lie or no nothing I would ever keep
from a child of mine meaning the truth
about no we're not married I have other
other people I'm sleeping with whatever
they asked me I would answer
I think as somebody that was raised by a
single mom like those things they they
don't matter as much to your child as
you think that they may I mean it did
have an effect on my relationships going
growing up but it's also something like
you can learn from that experience
through your parents you know like you
can as long as you have open
communication with your child and I
don't have any children but I have
younger siblings and I'm openly
communicative with all my family members
I think what's most important when it
comes a kid is their love in the house
do they see love between their parents
not not or they live in the way of of
making people that go to church happy
it's very downward deflecting question
you're asking me and I understand why
you're doing it however I'll put love
first in front of marriage every day of
the week because people get married in
America every weekend putting the
marriage and the Facebook pictures
before the actual love so I'll take the
love over all the [__] I think
that's probably true there's a lot it's
definitely true there's a lot of
hypocrisy out there for sure there's a
lot of hypocrisy and Christianity as
well like Bible thumping people that
want to beat you up with their views and
ask silly questions about things that
don't matter like is your kid going to
be upset that you have other women all
I'm worried about is being a good
[__] father and a provider and giving
them a life full of love and if I can do
that I've been quite quite successful in
fact I'd say more successful than most
Christians so my understanding my
understanding of Love is that it is
totally wanting the best for the other
person and that it's committed and that
it's sacrificial and that it's exclusive
it's faithful and Fidelity I think is a
really important part of love and if you
don't have Fidelity in love then you
don't have the security and the
opportunity for full vulnerability
no it wasn't late he says what are your
thoughts on whatever you want to tell
them
how do you feel about the Christian lady
uh I feel like she is annoying
like I feel the questions are being
asked five times and I feel like there's
a lot of questions that he already
answered well I grew what he says
unnecessarily but ask the questions
different way it doesn't change what
things like he doesn't care about what
you think lady he doesn't whether it was
he's right or delusional or whatever he
doesn't he doesn't give a [__] whether
he thinks that he's going to be able to
uh be with 100 people which I don't
think he really thinks that he's just
putting that
pathetically out there uh which like
it's the number is astronomical but I
don't think he really wants to do that
but yeah trying to like at this point
it's like you're repeating yourself so
yeah I think she's being a bit annoying
but I understand why she does that the
the Christianity thing I don't see how
that was really shot fired
people's like Oh shut fires him because
she's Christian or something like that
you already know what I think by the
Christianity and I I agree with the fact
that there's a lot of hypocrisy in
Christianity and stuff like that so
the what it looks like it's all cute and
everything and stuff but what really
happens it's just not what it is so
nothing according to what goes on in the
book and stuff like that so yeah
um apart from that what else did he say
the other thing that I said that I don't
think is really I think it is going to
affect the kid and that it is it is an
issue living I'm gonna live my life the
way I want to live my life on a project
unapologetically and I'm not gonna sing
for my daughters I'm like that's a bit
to me that's a bit off
because you don't know what kind of
person you're gonna try to you're going
to raise right and you figured most
people most parents figure that [__] out
once they have it and once they live
with that kid it's easy to say that I'm
not gonna do this I'm not gonna do that
I'm gonna be like this and when the
reality of a kid happens you got to
change a bunch of stuff in in order for
you to like to even have a conversation
or in order for you to be able to raise
that child if that's your point
um
sounds very
raising your kids house easier than it
actually is is a lot of parameters in
that there's a lot of things from
outside a lot and it's a lot of [__]
work it's not a cute thing most people
that's the thing
most people want to have kids
and I said I already most people want to
have kids
they don't want to be parents and having
a kid is having a possession being a
parent is a role that does not stop it's
harder than it is and yes you have to do
some concessions and you have to
reevaluate your positions you will bend
over backwards you will simply I mean if
you want to if you have decent parent
you have no choice especially when you
have a kid whenever you have it when you
have a kid that the kid doesn't
understand your rule that you have as a
parent he's being a kid or she's being a
kid they being kids that are discovering
the world it is we're like don't do that
they just discovering and let's see
but anyways do you
without confusion and stuff like that
but yikes
you're gonna figure out it's gonna be
different and what you think it is or
maybe not maybe you're right but that's
not what I think I just want to see
these examples I want to see these
examples of multiple families
all right where the kids are happy and
the wives are happy because even though
I don't necessarily believe in one
framework for all relationships one
thing she said that I did think was
interesting was the part about you know
through faithfulness you get security
and the ability for maximum
vulnerability and that doesn't make
sense to me if you're constantly feeling
like you know he's with someone else or
she's with someone else and they're
always spending time dividing it
everywhere whilst you're only because
their form is one man multiple women
right well while she's investing all her
time in the energy and the kid in him
he's he's dividing his attention
everywhere else so how do you feel that
kind of sense of security and deep love
and deep faithfulness and deep
vulnerability for somebody who gives you
ten percent of their time you get what
I'm trying to say so that part this
makes sense to me a bit but yeah
one can argue that you know well my role
is to bring the money and bring the the
materials and stuff and stuff like that
and she brings that other side which I
don't believe that's how it works
that has nothing to do with emotional
vulnerability the idea that you can
bring financial and all this stuff and
this is going to make someone feel
emotionally secure is just not the case
fair right like
they might feel financially secure which
is a huge stress off your back yeah
great but but the emotional side is like
another side they're constantly with
other women how you know if you find you
know any of these like they find out
they man was with other women on a
regular basis even thinking is she
better than me is she better more
attractive he's spending time with those
kids oh I've had a baby what's it you're
going to be having all because you got
too much free time
too much free time too much empty space
and then you all try to feel secure I
think it's just a very difficult
Prospect so I don't know me personally
I've just never seen these examples work
okay I've seen them happen unofficially
and officially my personal experience
life I've never seen them work well it's
dysfunction everywhere it's a lot of
chaos everywhere that has been my
personal experience I'm curious do you
guys have examples where this works on a
regular basis and everyone's content I
would love to see that no all right let
us know what you guys think